what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday january 20th
the joint is brought to you by
draftkings
this is the week if you're gonna make
money oh my god
if you're thinking about making some
guidance and having some fun at the same
time
this is the week and draftkings has the
fun for you
it starts tonight you got boston versus
philly
you got sac versus golden state then you
got saturday
you got conor mcgregor steps back into
the ring now if you want to be a piece
of history
go to draftkings the official betting
partner of the ufc
and this weekend they got a deal that no
one else could match you ready
dog you got to do this for a dollar for
just ufc
257 it's your shot at turning one dollar
into 257 dollars you're like joey how
does that [__] happen all right
you bet a dollar on mcgregor to win by a
knockout in the first round
and if he does you'll be cashing in 257
dollars
you bet a little you win a lot and you
know how we do it at [__]
draftkings
download the draftking sportsbook app
right now it's safe
convenient secure reliable and most
important it's your [__] money
deposit and withdraw at your convenience
so like i was telling you we got
mcgregor on saturday
and then sunday we come back with the
bills
versus [__] uh kansas city
and you got tampa bay versus green bay
both lines are three i think one is
three and a half
green bay a tampa bay's getting how the
[__] can [__] the man be getting
three and a half points
it's a weekend of fun you gotta start by
downloading the top-rated draftking
sports back
sportsbook app now use promo code joey
when you sign up
and turn 100 a dollar a dollar
into 257 dollars and then you take that
and you got sunday after [__] noon
you got the two and
the nfc and the afc championship place
your bet
watch the [__] fist fly this weekend
that's code joey for new players to get
257 dollars if mcgregor wins
by the first round knockout for limited
time only
at draftkings sportsbook right now today
you're going to open up
the app right now and here's the part
the lawyers make me say
you gotta be 21 or older go drink
[__] soda somewhere or something
smoke cigarettes under a bridge
[__] just like i did
new jersey indiana pennsylvania
tennessee colorado all these are invited
restrictions apply though see
draftkings.com
slash porch book for details now if you
got a gambling problem
you got to get help call 1-800 gambler
and if you're in indiana call 1-800-9
with it
but if you ain't got no problems and
everybody's ready to go and you're ready
to get your dick sucked on saturday
night
here we go download the draftking sports
book app
use code joey cash in on this deal
win some money snort blow duke whatever
the [__] you want to do it's your money
you understand me
but we're making money today go to
draftkings.com right now
code joey the joint is also brought to
you by lucy nicotine gum
listen it's the beginning of the year
you're still [__] smoking
this is the time you were supposed to
quit [__] uh 20 days ago
so when you're craving a smoke you see a
little something to help you with the
habit that's why i love lucy
dot co is [__] tremendous the
pomegranate tastes great
the winter green tastes great i love
them [__] both if you can see i'm out
of them because i use them they're so
good
get lucy today so you're prepared for
when you get the itch
it's a new year things might be rough
but you don't need to smoke anymore you
got to worry about your health okay
it tastes great i love the [__]
flavors
and i love lucy dot co and it's that
easy just broke
use promo code joey get 20 off all
products including
the gum or the lozenges that's lucy dot
co
use promo code joey at checkout also i
got to give you this disclaimer warning
the product contains nicotine derived
from tobacco
nicotine is an addictive chemical you
know that already but if you're looking
to stop
this will help you this will ease the
[__] cravings
go to lucy.com and be sure to use promo
code joey the joint is also brought to
you by
the third wheel in this pain management
of my surgery
cbdlion.com listen
i don't know much about cbd i didn't
until i started working with cbd lion
and then i started went on to my webpage
and i read what they had
and i read about terpenes i read about
the benefits
i read about how this company invested
money to find out
what cbd will help with your whatever
problem you
have which is anxiety pain
listen it doesn't clear it all away but
it [__] helps a lot i'm talking to
you guys right now
from [__] experience what i do is i
start in the morning with aspirins they
give you tylenol at the hospital i gotta
take two
500 milligrams i'm only allowed three
thousand a day i'll ruin my stomach
so i can't play around with that so what
i do is i get up in the morning i take
my aspirin and i put the rub on
the roll on listen look at this a
thousand milligrams of cbd i roll it on
all the way up to the stitches i don't
roll on the [__] thing i
cover it you know if at night i have
more pain
i put the tape on it they come with a
special tape and again
i surround it after i put the cbd
roll-on on it and let it dry and get
into the skin
i'm working it plus i'm eating the
[__] gummy bears at night and i gotta
be honest with you guys look listen to
me
do i look like do i sound like a guy
that's on [__] pain pills no
because i've been working it correctly i
don't want to get hooked i'm 50 [__]
eight years old
that's the last thing i need cbd lion is
the way to [__] go
especially right now with my surgery so
do me a favor go to cbd lion
and read the third party lab results
read about cb line and the benefits of
cbd itself
and how it could help you go to
cbdlion.com right now
and press in joey church and get 20
off delivered right to your house you
don't got to deal with people who don't
know what the [__] they're talking about
go to the webpage read order it's that
[__] easy cbdlion.com
i want to thank cbd lion i want to thank
lucy
dot co and i want to thank draftkings
now let's get this [__] party started
there's the [__] lighter
candles lick [__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
what's happening you bad [__]
it's wednesday the 20th of january
election day i hope you get the watch
this early i'm putting it out at 7 in
the morning
so you get to watch this before the
drama starts or maybe nothing will
happen i don't know what the [__]
gonna happen
but uh it's a beautiful day to be alive
that's all you need to know
first thing i wanna start off with is
this all right guys listen
i just had surgery if for some reason
i gotta get up uh
and go to the bathroom you got to work
with me okay
you got to work with me let me tell you
what happened as you know i had surgery
maybe 10 days ago on the 8th today's the
19th yeah like 11 days ago
uh before the surgery i remember talking
to tom segura and he said that uh they
gave him so much [__]
during the surgeries he had that he
didn't go to the bathroom for a [__]
week
i'm like god damn i forgot all about
that that the pills constipation and
whatnot
they filled me up with so much i don't
know what it's called dude
some [__] drug that dilaudid and
[__]
vicodins at the hospital they filled me
up with everything good
and then i came home with the oxycontins
and i swear to you guys
that i have been taking them by the book
i've even cut back on them
i'm doing the cbd with them the whole
thing they gave me nine
[__] prescriptions of pills basically
when i left the hospital from vitamin c
to like you know uh farm uh pharmacy
vitamin c that good [__]
not the [__] [__] that's chalky to
they gave me aspirin they gave me a
different type of tylenol
they gave me uh something for my anxiety
which make you kill yourself i'm not
taking that [__]
i'm not taking another [__] he's all off
to some [__]
but they gave me like uh these two pills
that you have to take at night so i take
them at 7 30 just to stay
and they go right through your [__]
system
and cut right through the [__] and
eventually you [__]
so the first thing they told me when i
left the hospital that saturday was
joey don't forget these these are the
most important things and
you know keep your diet light for a few
days you're not going to go to you know
you're not going to be able to go to the
bathroom
so [__] i've been the first night i
took them
i mean as soon as you take them and you
drink water you can feel the pills go
down your throat
and then like two minutes later you just
feel like
like you just feel like somebody just
grabbed your insides and just
just squeezed them for a second like
your whole body just goes
like the whole thing just burps like
that and then you just feel it go down
to your stomach
and then you hear some rumblings but i
didn't go to the bathroom guys
saturday sunday
monday or tuesday
when i first went to the bathroom
scout's honor i think you went monday
because he told me wear a suit when i
came over
that's right that's right i told him to
wear a [__] uh
a hazmat suit i it took me four days i
think
the first [__] was four days i think and
what came out of my ass smelled so bad
that i had to call mike and tell him to
wear or whatever i had
like i didn't let my wife down here i
mean if you thought
if you thought that bus ride in east
orange when the chili's
when mr baron told me that i was
changing flavors
if you thought that smelled bad what's
come out of my little muffler since then
and it's just like it started with that
one and then it took like another 12
hours to get another bow movement
but let me tell you something this
weekend i lived on the toilet
i'm talking about every [__] hour on
the hour
20 inches of unadulterated [__] [__]
coming out of my muffler
i'm sitting there sweating bullets you
know the whole [__] thing
plus i got to use the the [__] roland
to go in there
and then to get up and i got to take a
poop with my legs sticking out
it's terrible you can't even write this
[__] so
this has been going on since you know
like it started off slow
and then the pills really took control
of the [__]
and what's been coming out is like i got
to be weary
like i got to stay close to the house
and all this [__]
so yesterday morning i wake up and i do
two podcasts
two short podcasts for patreon for some
reason it won't let me
send a longer podcast and it's a easier
podcast it's 30 minutes
it's just a couple songs some uh me
talking [__]
and uh it's more intimate than than this
podcast i enjoy it to be i
i enjoy it as much as i enjoy this one i
i enjoy her anytime i gotta talk to a
mic
i'm having a good time i enjoy it you
know and
i'm doing it yesterday morning because i
get up on tuesday morning
i usually drink some coffee hang out and
then i do it
take a shower get ready do it and then i
send it to my managers
and then my manager puts it up for me so
i come in here usually just the same way
i do this when i don't turn on the
lights or nothing
it's not visual it's just audio i have
the little microphone i stick it into
the iphone
and i got the ipad and i play music and
i make my notes and i talk [__]
well i'm [__] taping a podcast and
i'm actually talking about
like you know it's been rough i've got
to go to the bathroom
in the middle of the podcast i had to go
to the bathroom
so i didn't know what to do i can't stop
it and restart it
so this is what i did i actually picked
up the little microphone
and my cell phone without hitting the
[__] button
and i took the thing and i wheeled
myself into the [__] bathroom
and i actually put it on the counter and
i kept talking and i took a [__] while i
kept talking about
why this music inspires me i was talking
about uh
the pretenders one and two of them why
they you know
why they inspire me so much but i
couldn't tell them
well you guys some of you just listened
to that podcast also i couldn't tell you
guys i was [__]
one person actually wrote you're a g i
could hear you pissed laying down how
the [__] what do you think i'm gonna
piss land [__] down
hell no i'm standing up when i [__]
piss i actually
took a [__] and pissed i tried to piss
as quietly as i could
so the microphone wouldn't pick it up
but the microphone picked up if you
listen to it
you'll hear me pissing i didn't flush i
just ran out of there and i flushed
after the podcast was off i washed my
hands
with [__] uh the deodorizer and i
worked it on the
towel and i threw the towel in the
[__] thing to get washed already
but that's what my day was like this
yesterday morning i had this
and i couldn't stop the podcast what am
i going to do stop and start all over
from scratch again
you're on a roll you got momentum going
so if for that reason if today i got to
stop the podcast in any moment
it's cause i got to go to the bathroom
all right we got that story out of the
way
because i don't want no
misunderstandings here that
joey sold me a short [__] script no
it was i got to go to the [__]
bathroom and when you gotta go
you gotta [__] go it's funny i got a
few emails about
the accusation podcast thank you for
listening to it
and it's you know listen man it comes to
territory
when you're a guy like me and you do
things
you're going to get accused of other
things of that nature
you know and the accusations never stop
so you know by you guys hitting me back
and telling me it reminded me of other
[__]
things that i've been acute like i got
accused of robbing a house
in 94
in boulder by a girl i was tight friends
with
now at this time i wasn't robbing houses
at all i wasn't doing anything on that
kind of [__]
robbing a [__] house i was calm as
hell i was doing comedy
yeah i was doing returns and [__] at the
kmart and stuff like that but i wasn't
robbing no houses i wasn't and nobody
knew i was doing this [__]
it was too embarrassing to tell people
i'm trying to be a comedian and i'm
still [__] shoplifting
are you [__] [__] so but i got a
cute i knew this girl really well i knew
her so well
i got her boyfriend a [__] job like i
liked her and her boyfriend so much
i got her boyfriend a job back in 91 we
were tight friends
and she had a buddy who sold weed in a
complex that was
next to mine did i like the guy
i liked him but he wasn't my best friend
i didn't dislike him
it's not that i disliked him i didn't he
wasn't my best friend
let's just say that he was an
acquaintance through her
and she wanted me to get him the same
job i got a boyfriend
so i couldn't get him that job anymore i
didn't know the people anymore i wasn't
connected to him and she kept bugging me
bugging me mugging me then he kept
bugging me bugging me and bugging me
about the job
and then one night this was right after
i got separated this was in the realm of
my separation
so i got separated i'm arguing with my
wife about the kid
i'm arguing with my wife about life
about who gets the couch
who gets the [__] car how we're gonna
sell the condo i got all these things
going at me
and in the middle of all this i get this
accusation
that was so far out of left field
especially in who i was at that time
i had already done time i had already
got my life together i got into comedy
i was away from all that i wasn't
robbing drug dealers nothing at this
time
i was doing drugs and i was having a
good old time but i wasn't robbing no
houses
this [__] lady and she was a weed
dealer and she actually called the cops
and they had the whole scenario painted
down like
behind my house where i lived on iris
iris on street or whatever 30th and iris
and boulder
there was a kmart and then across from
there where i lived there was like a
ludizio restaurant
there was a liquor store there was
murphy's bar and grill
there was the haircut in place there was
the [__] uh
the little italian place to do i told
him i was in the mafia he kept accusing
me of being in the mafia that i was a
relocated witness
so i finally told them what you think
you keep telling people i'm in the
[__] mafia
you're gonna get me in trouble in this
[__] town they kept telling people i
was in the mafia i'm not enough [__] the
mafia
i'm [__] cuban so finally i just told
the guy all right i'm in the mafia
now that you blew my secret you're gonna
pay a [__] vig so you're gonna give
me 300 a [__] week
i did [__] like that i'm not gonna lie
to you but i wasn't burglarizing no
houses trust me i was far from it
that's embarrassing you know what i'm
saying burglarizing the [__] house
they even because i went think there was
a pizza place called abose
i went to ablo's there and i don't know
what time i went there like i had the
baby that night or something
until like seven and then i went to get
a slice and i was going to do comedy
and about a week later and it was guess
who told me
my ex-wife came to me and she goes i
can't believe you robbed whatever's
house i'm like
are you [__] serious and it was going
to be a
it was almost in the divorce like this
she kept [__] talking about it
and i'm like first of all you know that
girl's a weed deal so if i robbed any of
their house they're saying i robbed weed
from them you're gonna get them in
[__] trouble
oh no they know for a fact that you
robbed him
and somebody's a dog till this that was
it's 2021. i forget what the people's
name was or whatever
but and that's what it does for a guy
like me
it doesn't bother me at all that you
accuse me of something i didn't do this
it hurts my feelings it's completely
different
it hurts my feelings it's a couple years
ago i remember six years ago
out of [__] nowhere out of nowhere
we're doing a podcast we're having a
great time with doug stanhope
the great doug stanhope accuses me of
robbing his change
jar or something like that like i was
blown the [__] away like i'm like
change jaw i could see and i didn't rob
his chain jaw
and he said it to me to break my balls i
was very hurt by him i wasn't angry
i was very hurt that i've known doug
since 1992.
we've had 2 000 conversations and one
day when he's on a podcast out of left
field
he says you accused me of right uh
stealing my change jar whatever the [__]
i was blown the [__] away i'm like
in 2016 whatever that was 2015
you're gonna come to me and tell me i
robbed a change jar from you in 2000
something
like first of all for people don't know
i've known doug stanhope since 1992.
we reconnected in 1995 in seattle
it was doug stanhope who talked me
into going into los angeles for comedy
once i got to los angeles doug stanhope
and i'm not ashamed to say this
gave me money out of his own pocket to
live a couple times
because i opened up for him on new
year's eve he asked me what did the guy
pay you for new year's eve
i told 250 dollars for five shows
doug stanhope got pissed he goes you
were worth a lot more than 250 than me
he gave me like 500 and then i saw him
again one night at the thing
i actually moved in with doug stanhope
in 92 when i lived with him
he was giving me cash like he was a guy
that i went to looked at and said doug
i need 20 bucks [__] gas and he gave
me his car
and 20 bucks to put in there for gas to
use his car that's the type of guy doug
stanhope is
when you got a friend like that you
don't rob those people
there's no reason to rob them they'll
give you the [__] off their back at that
time doug stanhope
was supporting like eight people and i
was one of them i mean he wasn't really
really really supporting me
he was letting me stay in his house for
free for free
and he was giving me 20s from time to
time
i mean i only stayed with doug for like
two months or something like that but he
was
my friend and even after i left doug's i
still kept going over there
ralphie may lived there for a while i
was there then
the mother came and lived with them i
was always at doug stanhope's house
you want me to tell you something man i
was thinking about this the other day
la changed when doug stanhope left
at least it did for me see doug stanhope
had everybody in check in la
that little [__] skinny dude that you
see like that
all [__] crazy he had [__] people
scared especially the half of [__] that
hang out at the improv and [__] like
that
because he would go into the improv and
lay a beating on those [__]
on stage so they would try to get him
banned
because they didn't want to follow him
this is when comedy was
very buckwild but it wasn't ready for
the likes of doug stanhope
doug stanhope took la by [__] storm i
still remember
mitzi shaw didn't even know what to do
with doug stanhope
that's how good he was mitzi sure i
remember one saturday night
the first week i was in town doug
stanhope had an
8 30 spot at the comedy store 8 45.
she admits he didn't know he was a
powerhouse she hadn't seen him enough
she passed them and then like kind of
forgot about him like he was never there
he's the road dog he was never there
only when he was in town but when doug
stanhope was in l.a
everybody was kept in check i'm talking
everybody because if you [__] up stan
hopes wrath came down on you
and that's a wrath at that time that was
worse than [__] that
i i mean i remember him going to the
improv
and he had those white boys [__]
dying
the people the comics i don't know at
the improv in those days and the comics
that i'm at the county store
were two different [__] sets
everybody looked down at the comedy
stuff
the comedy store was like a den of
thieves for [__] for drug people and
[__] like that i still remember
josh wolfe telling me that his
management told him don't go to the
comedy store dawg that's got a bad rep
in the early 2000s the comedy store was
[__] rough and tumbled
and the comics from there would branch
out to other places some of them
and they would cause [__] chaos
and nobody was causing more nobody
caused more chaos
in l.a from the time i got there to i
don't know when doug left l.a i know he
still has an apartment in l.a
i don't think he lives there anymore no
he doesn't he lives down in [__]
arizona down there
with the rest of those lunatics but once
he left
it was when people started acting the
way they did when doug stanhope was in
town
that [__] wasn't going on those clubs
because doug stanhope had
everybody in [__] check it was
hysterical the [__] they were doing to
people the comics he was blowing comics
he would rock so hard at the [__]
improv that three comics behind them
couldn't follow never mind
the guy behind him was worried three
guys behind them he was getting banned
every other week from the improv for
saying [__] i remember they did a
benefit for a burn victim one night
some poor burn guy and they put him in
the front row with like a skipper's hat
on
and he had like that stuff that they put
on you when you just got caught in the
fire like
gauze and doug stanhope went up there
with a couple beers in them
and nobody was laughing at his jokes
like people just left but doug stanley
was like what the [__] is real problem
even this guy this [__] burnt guy is
over here [__] laughing
he said something to that effect and he
got banned for like a month i mean
and the comics will get pissed like
comics you know
will go like i can't believe he acted
that it's a
[__] joke it's a [__] he was
joking around that's what the improv is
it's a [__] comedy club and he was
going down there and just
lighting them up and then when they
wouldn't take him the more he would come
to the comedy store
going back to that story i'll never
forget my first saturday
at that comedy store with that
[__] he had like an 8 45 spot
i was good friends with the girl that
had to follow him i forget
what her name was right now she
i mean she wasn't at the store at the
end she hasn't been at the store and
maybe
i've been off coke 13 years right 2007
13 years yeah because marilyn died
and i got off coke and she was good
friends of maryland and i forget what
her name was
sweetheart of a girl funny
but not funny enough to handle doug
[__] stanhope
like i'll never forget that that i
didn't even know her and i looked and i
go who's following you doug and he goes
that girl there and i go oh this is not
going to be good
doug stanhope went up there and
proceeded to destroy that room
and i'll never forget there was a
lesbian sitting in the front row
like a heavy-duty chubby lesbian with
the haircut the sideburns
the whole [__] thing and doug
stanhope
popped his head up and he goes what the
[__] is this
look at this [__] lesbo this is a
real lesbo
this ain't one of you la lesbos that you
know do it part-time or whatever
this one here she plays softball she's
got a [__] pump
she's i mean he just [__] drilled
into and all them is him getting off
and about 20 minutes later like he left
he had another spot
and i saw that chubby little lesbian
with another with her chubby girlfriend
and she was crying on her [__]
shoulder and stanhope said nothing to a
bad
stanhope i mean the girl walked in there
with the shirts rolled up and
the cigarettes in the [__] sleeve i
mean if you want to play with the big
boys if you're a woman and you roll
your [__] cigarettes up in your
sleeve when somebody you know you don't
get mad when somebody says something to
you especially if you're a lesbo
stan hope j and he didn't go off on i
would like how
an [__] would go off he went off on
her in a brilliant
you know how he [__] goes on his
rants they're brilliant rants
but all i remember catching from it was
the line of the night that he goes this
is a real [__] lesbian
she's got a [__] [__] pump she plays
double headers on saturday
she doesn't shave her snatch i mean he
was just [__] going off
and [__] she got i mean you know like
everybody in l.a hits him 20 minutes
later
while everybody's laughing having a good
time she was great then 20 minutes later
when stanhope left
she was outside complaining i've never
been insulted like that before in my
life well you got [__] sideburns and
you're a woman
somebody's eventually going to [__]
say something to you you know what i'm
saying
i mean i don't know what to call i don't
know where i come up with this [__] from
it just happens and
you got to look at it and go what the
[__] kind of life have you lived nah
this is comedy people your feelings
can't be heard every time somebody says
someone [__] color
now we're back to this [__] now people
get mad at whatever listen i've lost
some followers over the weeks i
i think people quit twitter because
trump quit twitter so
people going off the [__] twitter and
people going off of facebook
because they're saying private look i i
don't know i don't know what the [__]
going on
all i do know is we'll get a new
president today
do you want to know why what i feel dick
i don't feel dick about dick i don't
care if we get a new one
i don't care if the old one stays i
don't care if they bring back kennedy do
what you want to do
i still got to get up every day and poor
mike still gotta wear a [__] mask
bring back kennedy dig him up dig him up
with half his [__] head i don't give
a [__]
it's just you still gotta get up every
morning you still gotta live your life
you your loved ones are dying you're out
of [__] work and now i gotta worry
about who's [__]
president i just hope they do the right
thing whoever the [__] it is biden
camel i don't know conspiracy theories
the [__] people gonna get shot today
they just busted some guy last night
that was gonna shoot a missile
at [__] new york did you see that
[__] i mean who the [__] knows
so if this is the last time you see each
other whatever
whatever [__] khabib says come on
whatever the [__] he says god be it
i don't know i came to you early this
morning to let you know i love you and
we had a great time together
i don't know what's going to happen
after today if they're going to take
down the internet
they're going to bomb us we're going to
bomb them i don't know
but my heart goes out to you [__]
whatever you decide to do
anyway what else is going on in my
[__] world i got a thousand things if
it ain't one thing
it's the [__] other now i'm getting
accused
of i get accused
of something every week and i'm starting
to love it now
i'm starting to love it now this has
started this little [__] tate that
day i'm going to tell you
started two [__]
years ago two years ago
i went to play a club with kate quigley
and [__] my man uh dean del rizzi
we went to play a [__] club
as i do when i work with people you know
when we work together
we're flying i think we flew in thursday
night together
we hung out late in one of the rooms we
ordered room service
we ate everybody goes back to their room
and then the next morning we woke up you
know we had breakfast on our own and
then i usually meet
whoever i take with me on the road and
we do whatever the [__] we're gonna do
so i [__] uh
i get to the hotel meet dean and kate
hang out
whatever we go to bed we wake up friday
morning we got
that night friday night and then i think
we got boston on saturday night
i'm telling you guys the story right now
and before i was leaving you know before
i come to a town
people will hit me up and go hey i'm
excited
i've got two tickets i can't wait to see
you are we going to be able to take a
picture you know people always this is
a week before i come to your town i
start getting little twitter messages
facebook messages whatever people who
ask me and i can communicate yeah i'm
copying
you know also thank you you know i
always answer back
i'm not a big comedy star so i always
try to answer back as much as i can
so i answered whoever sent me this thing
and i said yeah great man i'll see you
at the [__] show
okay now i don't know about people's
personal lives i don't know what you do
before you come to the show whether you
rob the bank
i i don't know i don't know if you came
from a dealer's house i don't know if
you rape someone i don't know
i don't know i don't ask you at the
[__] door
okay i don't know i don't know what
reasons you're there for i don't know
what you expect from me i don't know all
i'm going to do
is do a show i'm going to do a show when
i go on the road i have no expectations
of anything
i bring my own weed i bring my own
edibles
and i try to keep it as contained as i
can
what do you mean by contained i try to
roll you know i was doing two podcasts
a week plus an extra one whatever i was
raising a kid
i was working out i was helping my wife
and then on the weekend i would go on
the road
so for me going on the road between us
is like a [__] vacation
like to go on the road for three days
between us
it's like a vacation for me what does
that mean
to be strictly honest with you i'll tell
you
when i went on the road early on
it was miserable i went on the road by
myself when i started comedy to
90 i started 91 i can't believe i'm
gonna be involved with comedy
30 years this year february is gonna be
30 years
i'm involved with comedy because i
actually got a job
at a comedy club as a doorman and
watched
so i've been involved with comedy for 30
[__] years so i'm 95
when i started doing triple runs and
stuff i was well
you know i was an old guy i was already
yeah 32.95 but
like i was young still i was a young
comic at 32.
what did that mean i went out to [__]
be a comic i went out to party
to do drugs and to have sex that's it
what do you become a comic for when you
sing when you're 32
to [__] bring a bible and read in
your hotel room no
you go on the road to [__] get high
and i just
i didn't i didn't start comedy at that
time i was just a road comic i didn't
want to go to hollywood
i didn't want to do movies i wasn't good
enough you know what i'm saying like
i was in prison i'm going to be lucky if
they do a background check to let me in
the club never mind tv and commercials
and [__] like that podcast
i just want to be a [__] comic okay
so
when i first started going on the road
i was a feature act and which means
you're a [__] understudy
which means you're a sack of [__] so you
go out
you get you know 250 dollars for five
shows on new year's weekend
okay and that's the type of money you
make some places will pay you
75 a show so my expectations were up i
would go out
go to the hotel room yeah you got to eat
the free food at the bar
because you don't have money to go to a
restaurant so you eat whatever they give
you at the bar onion rings that's why i
got up to 418 [__] pounds
because you're eating all this fried
[__] [__] but
but my first till 2002
i went on the road by myself and some
rooms then when i moved to la
and i became a regular at the store i
started headlining some room so i would
go out to some rooms as a feature
and i would do c rooms and d rooms as a
headline
you know it was every man for himself
you want to hear stories i got a
thousand stories a triple runs
you know [__] uh idaho falls
you know american falls the air force
base up there in idaho
you know when you do triple runs they're
from
probably i don't know in those days
there was another company that booked
milwaukee but whatever's
opposite to the west of milwaukee to
wisconsin
and in is all tribbleville and then
going down which is montana wyoming
colorado new mexico northern california
he had a partner that booked northern
california
all of oregon was tribbles and a lot of
stuff in washington
uh yakima uh
it doesn't matter tacoma a lot of stuff
was triple runs those rooms are a motel
sex
you go on the road you eat you know
sometimes you get laid
sometimes you don't you sleep with a
waitress whatever
but then i moved to la and i went out as
a headliner by myself
at first i was eating [__] i had a bag
of [__]
in jacksonville i had a bag of [__] on
all the creative runs i remember
dying such a slow death in charlotte
they wouldn't even take my calls normal
i was so [__] bad
this is going back to 98 99 but then i
got a new treat in life
a friend of mine by the name of joe
rogan started taking me on the road
and that was a great experience because
with joe was just great
it was me chris mcguire and joe at first
i was the emcee and then um
you know chris wasn't a regular at the
store chris is more of a writer
chris is a great guy he just hit me up
two days ago to check up on me in the
knee
still talk to him this is 98 uh
chris went on to write and then joe
took me on the road i was always having
problems like drug problems and stuff
so that's why joe started bringing hari
also
and duncan and it was just a [__]
party
i mean joe rogan is such a great guy and
he was so
[__] generous with us did he need
three openings no
but he still took us and he watched me
and he schooled me
and i'll tell you what man i loved joe's
way sorry i was looking at what i
thought you know spider
every once in a while you see a little
[__] spider downstairs
i like the way joe treated me the reason
i treat
feature acts or people who work for me
the way i do
is because the way joe rogan treated me
when i worked for him whenever you have
a chance if you'd like
hit leah and go was joey a [__]
gentleman with you
i took lead to comedy shows at the ice
house i didn't take lee on the road
because i had other comics that worked
and were feature acts and had to go on
the road
but anything lee did with me lee got a
dollar lee got money
and mike is the same way lee mike i
could weed whatever i get you
i'm in one of those guys in for a penny
and for a pound
that's the school of thought i come from
and you could go out to reach out to
dean delray
reach out to felicia who i spoke to
today uh yesterday
it was a great conversation i realized
how much i loved the
you know you could reach out to anybody
who's opened for me i take care of him
i take care of him because rogan took
care of me
weed whatever edibles malonga pills
whatever i mean me and ari have stories
and duncan about [__]
being in houston texas and there was
this guy who still comes to my shows
today 20 years later
who used to bring his jars of vicodins
and [__] and we didn't know what to do
with him like what do we do with these
we would give them away at the club to
all the comics and [__] like that
but that's how long when when i went on
the road with joe rogan
i learned how to like
he taught me how to economize how to
base
make the best out of my road work like
how to do it
the most efficient way you know you're
flying the night before
you go to mike joe rogan's a [__] hat
joe rogan would take us like
he has to constantly area at the hotel
what's the best restaurant
in town this one let's go
we go to the best restaurant in town get
what you want on the [__] menu i
think he's my brother
well i think i love him so much what i
think i laugh at you guys
i laugh at the people who make remarks
about him
because he helped so many [__] comics
he helped groom
so many comics and i was one of them he
helped groom me he was
i was like his [__] frankenstein he
helped groom me he would tell me go up
there say that [__] joke
[__] it commit do it he would like other
[__]
i could name 10 comics that have told me
not to say that joke in front of me or
you're too crazy you're on wild he
[__] loved it
he [__] loved it and the crazier i
was the more he loved it you know who's
the same way about me
gabriel glaciers they're crazy you ever
remember that comedy central show he had
that he put me on he paid for the show
to put me on he went to war with comedy
central
he's like put on a suit and come out
[__] throw and eat
i love those [__] because of
that because they had my back
so because those guys treated me the way
they did this is the way i
treat my [__] features so i go all
out with these [__]
so anyway back to the [__] story so
meet kate and dean go eat
and on the way back it's a casino we
asked the security guy
where's where we go smoke the guy asks
us
he goes you guys aren't smoking in the
room or he will like no
because if you want to go smoke i got a
spot for you
so security guy yeah the security guy
this is great
so me dean dean doesn't smoke weed and
near this kate
but that kind enough to come with me and
we go outside to the smoking balcony
and we smoke this junk now one of the
people who told me they were coming
to the show that they bought tickets and
the whole thing
i'm not gonna mention no names on here
but that person came up to me and said
hi i'm coming to your show i'm excited
she smelled the wheat on us she goes did
you guys just smoke we go yeah we're so
sorry but we might smoke later on i
think
kate even stayed with her and hung out
with her
kate went somewhere with her well they
went to the bar for a drink
the show ends i i don't see i go back up
to my room you know
like i said when i go on the road is to
[__] relax guys
i can i could i could name you
in the last since what have we been
doing this since 2013
to 2020 to february 29th of 2020 my last
road week
i could name the 10 people who have been
in my hotel room
and 10 people whose hotel room i've been
in like dean always comes in my hotel
room
you know uh kate quigley always comes to
my hotel room if i'm
if i'm in vegas like if i do vegas and i
bring them with me i get such a big room
that i order food and they give me a
food allotment
i order food and i tell them to come
over i'll call them and go what do you
want from the menu
look i order and we all eat together in
my room on this particular day
we went to one of the restaurants in the
casino we went downstairs people were
coming up to us
but this particular person came up to us
and said how you guys doing
you know blah blah blah oh it's a shame
that you guys smoked already
i wanted to smoke with you i go listen
we might come back and smoke later on
and we'll give you a [__] call
or we'll let you know are you staying in
a hotel room yeah whatever
now between you and me guys um
when you have a secret spot at a casino
you don't really want to smoke with 20
people
because then it's not a secret number
now they both they blow up your [__]
spot
so i didn't we didn't come down again i
think i popped edibles
i went out there and i did my time we
all did our time and then what do you do
at a casino i go outside
and i took pictures and shaked hands
with people
i go back to my room and the next
morning we're headed to boston
and on the drive to boston
kate goes did we see that girl
at the show i go no she didn't [__]
take a picture with us
all that [__] all those emails and
[__] and no
you know she didn't take a picture with
us
i don't know what the [__] happened we
go to boston
you know i don't have facebook on the
road so i go to boston i do the two
shows in boston
we get up sunday morning we got on
jetblue and we head back to l.a
never thought about it again i get into
my [__] house
i go on facebook and i got a message
from the girl telling me that she passed
out
that she passed out she got drunk and
she can't [__] believe it she's angry
at herself
for not coming to the show she want to
kick herself in the ass and i said
listen
i'm sorry it happened also i go next
time i do boston
or something like that i'll just throw
you a ticket or whatever
the last last time i did boston i
offered a ticket
and she couldn't go so
i didn't think not nothing nothing you
know how it goes you live your life
boom i think about
four months later i got an email that
from some guy
that [__] his girlfriend came to my
show
that she left him at his house
and she went to the show that means she
came to the show
and she wanted to [__] one of us or she
he's accused us
or whatever he doesn't know if it's me
or dean
and i'm [__] laughing my ass off i'm
like
this is the [__] that it doesn't piss me
off
but it just goes to whatever i didn't
think nothing of it
i didn't even answer i got this email i
didn't even know what they were talking
about
they said their girlfriend came to the
show and didn't take a boyfriend with
him
so what would you do mike if your
girlfriend went to a show without you
do you go back and go what the [__]
happened we were supposed to go to a
show together i don't know i don't know
what type of people do this i don't know
what's going on
so all i know is what's that email the
comic
no i don't [__] know i don't know
nothing
i i get back i said okay so she got
drunk and she couldn't make it to the
show i didn't know nothing
now i got an email from the girl's
boyfriend that he left her there
that [__] that means she was up to no
good this girl's a good girl from what i
see on facebook
she's a mom for christ's sake but i also
thought about a roommate not a roommate
i had a friend that i lived with
and he let a friend of his stay on the
couch for a few
months uh after his divorce
and i remember that he you know i would
try to be like an ear to this guy
and i would ask him why did you you know
why did your wife throw you out or
whatever
and you know the first two weeks it was
always the same story we didn't get
along
she's a [__] [__]
you know whatever and i took it you know
i just gotten separated
so i just you know we were just in here
for each other
the guy had a weird name his name was
mudge
so that's what we called him the street
name was mudge fudge
i don't know he tells me after two weeks
he goes you know what the real problem
was and i go what was the problem he
goes
back in high school she [__] a friend
of mine
i go whoa so you've been with this chick
since high school
he goes no we went to high school
together
we graduated she went to a college i
went to a college
and then when we came back we went to
work at a summer program and we both met
at the summer program
and we you know we had the same friends
and blah blah blah blah
and then we got married everything was
fine i think one night she told them
like after they were married so this
happened
and when i stayed with
my friend manny it had to be 94
93 and i was 31 years old this guy was a
few years older than me
and i'm like what and he goes this whole
[__] thing started because she slept
with a friend of mine in high school i
go were you with her
and he goes no i wasn't with her but it
doesn't [__] matter she's a [__]
[__] and i'm like
you got kids with her you got kids with
her and you're [__]
bringing up somebody she slept with like
her junior year in high school that she
didn't know you
but there's guys that are out there like
that that they'll love to [__]
pick fights with women over something
they did before you were [__] around
listen go upstairs to my wife right now
and tell us something i did before we
met
sugar go [__] yourself like the time
when the when the [__] from 97
she goes i got no claim in that [__]
[__] that's what a real person does
you can't control what your girlfriend
did
before she met you or what your
boyfriend did you accept them for who
they are today and you live with it if
you don't like it then don't date them
no more
if you got a problem with them sleeping
somebody that in 1980 [__] seven and
it bothers you still today
i think you got a [__] problem so
that's all he said to me was i
i think you slept with my girlfriend
somebody slept with her she wouldn't
have left
without me i know uh okay
what do you want me to do nobody slept
with her like i said i don't i didn't
see her after that so
what the [__] do you want from me now so
every month i'm getting hit from this
guy
hey man you ruined the relation what the
[__] are you talking about so
yesterday morning i wake up did you see
that somebody posted my address
no like a fake address on twitter yeah
on twitter
like on twitter on instagram or whatever
they post like a face thing and
they're gonna come beat me up cause i
slept with their girlfriend
and all this [__] i haven't slept with
nobody who the [__] wants to sleep with
me
what the [__] wants to sleep with me you
know what i'm saying
this girl i got this girl by 20 [__]
years she wouldn't look at my dick she
yeah she's a fan of the [__] podcast
and she's a fan of reefer that's just
she's a fan of she's not a fan of
[__] joey dear
she doesn't give a [__] she wouldn't
nobody came to those shows
to [__] sleep with me unless you're
[__] crazy unless you're [__]
crazy i'm an old [__] man
but till this day have you heard from
her oh yeah she you know on facebook we
talked from time to time she never
brought it up but yesterday morning she
was calling me [__] on facebook
you know what's that thing when they
messenger [__] i didn't hear it i don't
hear it i don't know what the [__]
people think that
are you supposed to hear a phone ring on
messenger sometimes you get a setting
right and what do you hear okay it's my
mind just it's not
sometimes it just has like a phone
ringing and it's like a messenger phone
call
oh no i never forget i don't hear
nothing but this is what i'm talking
about i mean
so you know in my world accusations
have been flying since they [__] won
but this one is just so [__]
far-fetched
and for it to still be going on
two years [__] later
either you should have dumped a buy now
if you didn't trust her
because that's what this is basically
about that you don't [__] trust him
so then just dump her but you're going
to come after me
you're going to say things to dean
you're going to say things to me what
the [__] is wrong with you
what the [__] is wrong with people and
that's what's been eaten
that's what he eats at me what listen
you know how many times people have hit
me up already since i've been doing the
podcast and said to me you [__]
i knew was you who robbed me in 83 i'm
happy you admitted it on the [__]
podcast i was going crazy you know how
many of those i've gotten
20. and we're all cool it happened
[__]
there's a chick's house i robbed
december 18 1983.
guess what i still talked to her on the
phone she found out through a podcast
that i robbed her
and she [__] hunted me down called me
and she was like you [__] robbed me
you son of a [__]
guess what i was gonna call it two years
i was talking to her three years ago
i go about going up to aspen and
visiting her she had me at a condo for
me and my wife from the kid that's
that's how cool i am with people now
they just wanted to know the truth
that's it i'll tell you the [__]
truth you want a little truth i'll tell
you the [__] truth
i didn't sleep with nobody nobody nobody
i doug if you look at my dick and balls
let me tell you what
what happened okay let me tell you how
bad things are when you're 58 years old
so i gotta i can't you know when i got
home from the hospital they told me i
couldn't [__]
i couldn't take a shower because of the
stitches that's great
you know that lasted [__] a day and a
half okay
one whiff of my nut sack and what
happened was my wife
was wrapping my leg with the thing she
was actually
what me and my wife do is basically i
get up i come down here
i put the sink on the first day and you
know i get like a hot towel
i kept the shower running i had to hold
on to a [__] stool
and i would wipe my armpits there my
balls and then she would wipe my back
and stuff i don't want my
wife wiping my [__] on my dick
but the one night she was rubbing my leg
she was putting something on my leg
and she had to be like eight inches from
my nut sack maybe her foot
and she actually said something to me
she's like hey man i love you to death
we've been together for 20 years
but you got to do something about those
balls i could smell them from here
i go done so now we're wrapping my
[__]
you think i'm [__] kidding you we
wrapped my leg like with a saran wrap
and i take the [__] stroller into the
shower
and i just sit there i i wet myself up
up up up and i take it i'm not there is
no
[__] way i'm doing little [__] you
know hot water bats whatever and you
know like i got home on saturday
and i took like a good hot water bath
after the hospital
she wiped me down and then saturday
night we did another one because you
know me i like to be clean i'm a fat
dude i got weird odors coming out of me
so that sun saturday night i did the
same wash again
switched underwears you know me dog i'm
buy the book
i got 3 000 pay underwears me undies
upstairs
they kept sending me underwear all those
years so i if i put
i put a pair underway and fart i change
[__] underwear that's how [__]
solid i am so i took the [__]
underwear
you know i took them off and she told me
she's like dog
i don't know what's in that area there
and i stopped taking
these pillows see i was taking this this
gnc testosterone package
healthy men's testosterone oh
oh let me explain something to you
the smell of your piss
when i take alpha brain and shrimp
attack and shrimp
sport and [__] nothing stinks like that
gnc has one pill in there in there
[__] men's testosterone that makes
your piss
smell so bad i'll tell you how bad it
makes your piss smell
and you know again we got no [__]
secrets between us
there are times i am sitting watching tv
and i could actually smell my piss
that i just pissed when i did the
sopranos i had to pull the wardrobe lady
aside and go look
don't smell those pants whatever you do
dry clean those [__] because
every time i pissed i had a piss in a
hurry because there was only one
bathroom for covid
and every time i put you ever put your
dick back in your pants and there's a
little leakage and you're like god damn
it
that's what was going on that day i was
pissing so much that i was rushing and i
was putting my dick back in my underwear
and then my underwear would smell like a
[__] goat so i said [__] it
i had to tell her after the first night
of shooting i go
do me a favor send those right to the
[__] dry cleaners
because they [__] stink so [__]
bad
she was like okay i was so embarrassed
like i had to pull her aside because i
didn't want her to get the whiff
to be folding the pants and to go what
the [__]
so thank god ever since i stopped
lifting weights last thursday
uh the seventh i stopped taking those
testosterone pills there's not
testosterone
like a boost or whatever i don't even
know if it works or not
somebody gave me a sample and it felt
good so
i stopped taking those so if without
them
i could see with those pills my dick and
my bulk combination stinking up a storm
but without those [__] things for
your balls to still stink that's [__]
embarrassing in my world
so we'll [__] shake hands and part
friends i went and took a shower and
i've been taking two showers a day
ever since this [__] surgery i just
wrap my leg
up with [__] saran wrap brother and
boom
i go in there so my wife is telling me
to my face that my balls stink
how do you think i feel in my head like
in my head i've known for eight years
since i've had mercy and since i was
like 49 i'm like
i can't show this dick to nobody no more
this the ugliest thing
in the world the morning of my surgery
when they put the intravenous in me
i was so [__] scared that day i had
shrinkage issues
in the [__] in the emergency room my
dick
went all the way in when i tell you that
my dick shrunk to an inch for four days
after the surgery
i'm not [__] lying to you i don't
know what the [__] it is about surgery
but my dick helmet went all the way in i
still remember before the surgery i had
a piss
i told you [__] the dude tiger
i got a piss he goes i don't worry about
it
we'll put a tube in your dick if you
have to piss during the surgery
and then we'll pull it out i go no you
will not do that [__]
no you will not i will piss right here
they had to bring that
the catheter whatever the [__] that
thing is and i remember a girl holding
it she's like i got it
i couldn't even grab my dick to piss in
that piss
was just sprinkling everywhere like like
a [__] brooklyn [__] sprinkler
head
it just kept [__] going around around
in circles
so i was like jesus [__] christ this
is the most embarrassing thing
they even told me at the hospital like
friday night i think it's time to change
your robe
because i had a piss in the bed so i
kept pissing the thing and little bits
of piss would go out
i didn't that room smelled like [__]
debt so these are all the reasons
why i wouldn't even consider like we
[__] around
i'll show you my balls on the internet
if you like i've showed you my balls
before
you know that the guys the boys love to
see the balls
those comedy [__] they love
when i take my balls at the comedy store
they loved it for years i did it it was
a goof but to show them to a [__]
girl at my age
ever since i was 50 that's been the last
thought on my mind guys
and listen everybody loves a good blow
job or a good piece of ass
for me it's been a complete different
opposite of that because
what do i tell my little daughter what
do i tell my daughter
that i can't be a father no more because
i cheated on her
i'm gonna lose all this because of my
[__] daughter so it's
never even been on my [__] curriculum
it's never been on my [__] curriculum
you know look at the friends i have the
women that are in my life they're
[__]
beautiful kate quigley you wouldn't try
something with kate quigley really
oh you're that much of a christian i've
never tried 91k christian
one time [__] around when i told me
this to show me those skinny [__]
tits or whatever
but no she's my [__] best friend my
sister felicia michaels
beautiful piece of ass wasn't playboy
ask her
ask if i didn't come on to felicia
michael there's no need to
she would look at me and go and joey i
would never i mean felicia says the
funniest [__] things
you've ever heard in your life when i'm
alone with her we want to take it to
this comedy show one night
and we bumped into a well-known musician
that will
will leave unknown i mean he's one of
the biggest musicians of all time
he was at a [__] comedy show and
we're walking out me and her
and a friend of mine says hey have you
ever met this guy and i go
no and i'm like hey man very nice to
meet you
i'll just give you a hint he's got a
radio show i shake his hand i go very
nice to meet you
you know it's a pleasure i love your
band uh this is my friend felicia
michaels because felicia came with me
felicia shook his hand we turned away
what right most people would go i can't
believe that's [__] blah blah blah
you know what felicia said to me
she goes i think he needs some air
conditioner
his hair is a bit on the dry side i go
is that what the [__] you just noticed
when you meet
one of the biggest musicians in the
[__] world that his hair needs
conditioning that is
dry you know they're [__] 80. so they
gotta keep dying their hair
jet black so eventually your head gets
[__] you know [__] it just sizzled
it
but that's that's her world ask her i
remember one i remember felicia michaels
had to take a picture
i went to a house one morning i was
laying there and i go you know what
i need a [__] album cover for my cd
i need an album cover what the [__] did
i take a picture of my balls for
there's the um the documentary where i
got my
boss from the vote yeah i'll never
forget
i was laying there and i'm like where
what kind of cover
can i possibly put on this [__]
documentary
i'm bending my knee 90 degree guys
already 11 days
and i'm [__] in i keep working too i
don't give a [__]
but ooh look at that how's that for you
[__] you see that
doing my own therapy by the way i start
therapy tomorrow
uh what am i considered an outpatient
now
because the inpatient people don't come
over here no more i'm an outpatient now
so
back to this felicia story i [__] get
up one morning i'm like what kind of
album cover am i gonna put on this go
it's quit where i got my balls from
i gotta have my balls in there somewhere
or picture balls
or something so i said let's call it
let's do this the right way
[__] it i'll uh i'll take a picture of
my boss
now i gotta find somebody to take a
picture of your balls who can i [__]
possibly have to take a picture of your
balls
if you go to a guy he might punch in the
[__] face
and if you go to a woman they might
charge you with
he tried to show me his [__] balls
that's what i needed my life right now
but me and felicia were cooler than that
so i just called her up i go felicia do
you have five minutes
i want to talk to you face to face you
know i don't you don't want to ask
somebody to take a picture of your balls
on the phone
because by the time you get there the
cops will be there waiting for you
you want to ask them to their face so if
they do decide to call the cops
you got time to run you know even though
she was my best friend at the time
i'm a little worried about this question
so i call her up i go felicia
do you mind if i come over and ask you a
personal question she's like come over
nobody's here i go over there i roll up
a joint can i talk to you about
something i go felicia i have this
documentary
i go it's called where i got my balls
from do you mind taking a picture of my
ball sack
dog she just froze and she looked at me
like
then she goes i'd love to and i go all
right get the camera and she got the
camera
i took my dick i held it she did not see
my dick i did not show him my dick
i held it up here like a [__] gun and
i just kept my legs open
and she came right in and zoomed in with
him and she came as close as it could be
and took a picture of him she put the
camera down she looked me in the face
and she goes
those are sam balls that was it right
there
she showed me she took like eight
pictures she showed them to me and she
goes
they were kind of scary that was as
close up as i could get with
i'm getting scared of them she goes that
big vein in the middle of them
that's the scariest vain i've seen on
nut sacks and i've seen nut sacks before
they're my [__] best friends you know
man right now i came around to them why
would i come on to some [__] check
that was coming to come see me
so the point of this [__] story is
again with the [__] accusations
that i slept with somebody's [__]
girlfriend i mean it never [__] stops
a couple weeks ago what about the dude
before i left california
there was a room i cheated on my wife i
said i told my wife something about some
[__] lady
it just it never [__] ends so don't
believe everything you hear
so far in the last 10 years i've been
podcasting
i tell you what's on my mind and i'll
tell you as embarrassing as it is
i've told some very embarrassing stories
about my life on this podcast
and the things i've done and things i'm
not [__] proud of
but i told them anyway i told them
anyway i don't give a [__]
you're my therapist guys that's what you
guys don't understand
when you come to do a podcast if you're
not talking to your audience
or your family and you're being as
honest as you can
as you would be with a psychologist or
your therapist or whatever the [__]
then why are you doing this if i'm gonna
come here and tell you a half story
i'm not gonna waste your time i'm gonna
tell you the whole story so you know the
truth
i want you to know the [__] truth i
don't give a [__] about what i did
yeah i robbed this guy rob that guy did
drugs i did this
you can't take that away it's already
done you have to judge me by what i'm
doing today and how i'm living my life
today
do you understand me that's how you
[__] judge me i'm how i'm living my
life today
whatever happened 97 or 98 even for you
guys i have no control over
that as far as i'm concerned it didn't
happen you're a different [__] person
i don't give a [__]
and mike's gonna be not you know if you
rape somebody
i'm not gonna be [__] nice to you but
if you did a common [__] mistake
and i see that you a gentleman today you
got my [__] love and respect that's
how i work it
i don't give a [__] about people's past
at all as long as you're a decent person
today you took care of those [__]
things
and you know what the last i checked i
took care of those [__] things
the last good thing i [__] did was i
called somebody
that lent me money i swear to god this
guy lent me money
24 years ago he never asked for it back
he never asked for it back i always kept
in touch with him i was always very
grateful to him
he got into a spot in like 2007 and he
goes hey man
i need to collect that money do you mind
and i go brother
i don't have it and he goes i don't
understand how you can't have it you've
been doing comedy
for so long now you did the longest shot
i did the longest shot in 2004.
whatever money i had from the longest
yard i paid debts often of 10 previous
[__] years
i didn't have your number i didn't know
how to get a hold of you we had lost
contact
i'm very [__] sorry say i can't
believe i'm coming to [__] la
and you're not going to have my money
i'm going to need this i go what could
you
listen if there's anything else i can do
for you i'll do it for you if you want
me to start sending you payments he goes
no
i mean this was after he lent me the
money in 95.
this is 2000 [__] seven or 2008
i hadn't heard from the guy i knew he
was in dire needs
so he called me and
like i called him back like two weeks
later to say listen what if i gave you
and i'll make payments and he didn't
answer the phone
he never returned my [__] number i
called and i called him like a month or
two
later and he had changed his number and
i don't know what the [__] happened to
him
i started making money and i put away
that money that he gave me
because i was going to give it to him as
an investment he bought me a car
he gave me money for clothes i think he
let me like 1500 [__] bucks
you're not gonna believe this story he
lent me 1500 [__] bucks
to get my life started mike tesla my
uncle mike the one that was on the
podcast all [__] up
but he calls up from time to time he
sold me the car he got me the nissan
it was the car i took on the road for
years i was indebted to that guy
if you know anything about me guys if
you do anything for me i'm indebted to
you
never mind [__] start my career this
guy jump started my [__] career
triple called me on like a [__]
thursday to go out on the road
for six weeks i didn't have no [__]
car i was like take a rental
and he was the one that said why don't
you find a little cheap car and i'll
lend you the money to you get on your
feet
i [__] bought the car blah blah blah
blah blah anyway to make a long story
short 2007
2008 he calls me he's very upset with me
i was very upset with him
i didn't know how to get a hold of him
i started making a little bit more money
you know just and i put away some money
and i
tried to call him i called a bunch and
every time i went to [__] denver
every time i went to wendy curtis at the
comedy works
i would call my friends in boulder and
say anybody know how to get a hold of
this guy anybody see him
anybody do anything nobody do nothing so
for the last three [__] years i've
been sitting there going how the [__] do
i pay my
payment out to this guy okay about two
months ago
again facebook messenger is like
the thing i do when i'm the most bored
because it's the last line of defense
once i've answered the twitter message
messages once i've answered the facebook
messages
my hotmail messages that's the last line
of defense i'll go on
messenger and find 200 [__] messages
that i haven't read and i'll go through
them if they're like if it's somebody
wishing me a happy birthday
you know it was a [__] year ago what
am i going to do thank you now
i'm already ungrateful in that [__]
eyes but if it's somebody who's like a
friend of mine that's trying to get a
hold of me
i saw this name it kind of rang a bell
and i opened up the email and it's like
hey how you doing i worked with you at
colorado sports advisors
what's going on do you still talk to
some of the old guys
he goes i know they'd love to hear from
you and he just put the names out in
their phone numbers
and he put that kid's number that i owed
money to
[__] i was so happy i called them up
and this is just before this is
right after i got here he [__] hit me
up on facebook
i caught i got the number i called it
was a long ring
they're not gonna pick up my call
because they see the area code
three two three nobody knows where it's
coming from and then you see the name
jose diaz
and you're like i'm not [__] nobody
puts it together right away
so i left a message hey man this is joey
diaz you called me a couple years ago
you know i didn't have the money for you
i got your money today
i didn't hear from him for like two days
he called back he's like
is this really you like oh it's really
me man
he goes do you really have the money
like i really have your money he goes
you don't understand how bad i need that
money right now
he gave me 1500 you don't want to know
what i gave him as an investment back
i mean it was a 20 [__] year
investment i had to make good on it
i sent him the doe now we're friends
you know when i went down to uh
every time i go down uncle vinnie's on
wednesdays i use a different friend of
mine to give me a ride
i use either cops that are still working
you know and i try to throw him a couple
yardsticks
or friends of mine that have felons
and they can't work but they carry a gun
and they're still [__] nuts
you know i always try to pick somebody
every wednesday that could use the money
really bad
you know or he's a dear friend of mine
and i have like
four ex-cops i got like two cops that
are still cops
and i got like three criminals and i
alternate
in between uh all three of those all
[__] six of those guys
for different rides you know and i give
them a couple little
a couple hundred just because hey that's
what the patreon is for
and that's what this whole thing was for
you know the last time i went down there
uh my friend luke my nephew luke gallo
he's a cop and he was telling me that
you know
dave portney the owner of ball school
sports i'm a big fan of
um put away 26 he put a fund together
like
26 [__] million dollars to help our
business
you know guys i didn't know anything
about it to help out businesses and
uh whatever i think [__] uh
restaurants
so i think like aaron rodgers donated a
half
a mil to save a restaurant
that he really liked you know
a couple people quarterback from tampa
bay gave money
a lot of people are giving money i'm
gonna give a donation to dave portney
out of the patreon account this week uh
once we they pay us on the fifth of the
month
whatever for restaurant owners or
whatever but i just want to let you know
that i've been doing my part
on the patreon i'm not looking you know
you can't help everybody guys
but i gotta help the people that are
closest to me first
i gotta help the people in my circle a
lot of comics
you know that they're hurting so that's
what i use my patreon for to help a lot
of those people out
two 300 400 bucks a month
you know three or four or five people
you know i got my drivers
that i'm trying to help out you know
mikey we're all trying to help each
other out here man
and uh this is what i do
with the p money is i try to just you
know
i can't help a business i wish i could
help a small business come back
but i've been just trying to help the
people that are the closest to me in my
inner circles
as much as i can you know tonight before
we started
you saw i got a i had to call a friend
and you know tomorrow he has to go for a
bunch of tests
he doesn't have a car so he has to rent
the car and that's what we do
that's that's what we're doing right now
we're helping out
the people that are around us but uh i
just want to let you know
what we're doing as the joint uncle
joey's joint and the mind of joey diaz
what we're doing with that patreon money
you know i'm not making big money here
nobody's [__] eating out of nothing
we're trying to help individuals little
comics
guys that you would never hear of or
want to hear of guys that
you know and there's some people i just
send a but they call boost
you know our job here is to make
somebody's day
that's what our job is mike when you
come here i always give you a little
weed right
sometimes it's two nugs but i always try
to make somebody's day
that's your mission forget about who the
[__] the president is today
who gives a [__] your job to this
country and what you all america is this
be nice to somebody every day one
[__] person
be kind especially what we're going
through right now
call them be kind you know give somebody
a bud
i mean i love to give mike a pound i
don't have a pound
but if i had a pound half of it would be
his you know in my world i'm like
you know the the worst people in life
you know when i watched that documentary
the 7-5
i got to meet mike dowd you know on
paper mike dowd a lot of people think
he's crazy
but there's one thing i know for a fact
about my dad that i've heard it from
people if mike dowd has two dollars
and you need it my dad will give it to
you whether he robbed it
whether he stole it from a drug dealer
and in my world that's all that [__]
matters
you know if i got two pieces of rice
mike's gets one
and if i got three mike gets two because
he's got a kid at the house
or we split the third half goes to my
kid
and half goes to mike uh mike's kid
that's how we do it here
so in retrospect and in closing that's
what i wanted to talk about today that
this podcast
and my world is about making somebody's
day i know this podcast was all over the
place today
but i enjoyed it i enjoyed telling these
stories i'm sorry about the commotion
up there with this guy and his
girlfriend and the grief that they're
going through
the guy got on patreon to [__]
threaten me so i had to tell him to go
[__] him so remember the podcast i did a
couple weeks ago
about how i'm prepared if somebody wants
to [__] around
it's hysterical how that podcast was
taken out of content
and how people thought it was meant
towards them i love that type of [__]
a guy like me loves that type of [__]
now if you know anything about
lee hit leah and ask lee
lee has given me the biggest compliments
of my life
because we worked together for eight
years we knew each other and lee once
told me he goes bro you're very
calculated
he goes i realized by working with you
that you're very calculated
you don't do anything unless there's a
payoff unless there's a movement
and that's what i try to do when i tell
these stories is tell movement it's
hysterical
i told the story on a couple weeks ago
how i'm prepared
and other people took it the wrong
[__] way there's a whole podcast
about it
yeah the whole [__] thing
and [__] people took it as the wrong
way and i love it
because i was just letting the right
people know listen if you got a [__]
problem with me you want to [__] around
bring it give yourself a try whatever
especially over some girl that nothing
happened you're wasting your time
if you're that untrustworthy if you
don't trust a person you love that much
don't deal with them
and go to a [__] class and learn how
to get trust issues
and how to trust people and how to love
people again you know we've been
together for 20 years
i don't give a [__] about what my wife
did before she met me i know she had a
past i don't care
i don't ask it's got nothing to do with
me and it's not in my business
my business is to provide happiness for
her
today the same thing with all my friends
whether it be mike whether it be jimmy
florentine
i love all you [__] the same so
i was just letting you [__]
know
i'm in jersey i'm in my backyard here
even on my block i got two cops my
backyard is watched by a [__] cop all
day long
that loves me to death he lives three or
four doors down if you've noticed i've
always lived next to cops
i've always been frank with them it's
about weapons they know i'm felons you
don't think they know they know i'm a
[__] felon i don't want to know but i
don't give a [__]
it was a mistake i made and i did it and
we're done with but it's so funny how i
did that podcast
and other people started getting scared
he's talking about me
nobody gives a [__] about you you
[__] jerk off
that's it and that's that [__]
we've made it through another week
it's election day i hope you watch this
podcast nice and early
listen i don't know what's going to
happen today i'm not a psychic i just
know that
their troops on their way to washington
they're not allowed to have people
i don't think there's going to be people
out the inauguration i don't know what's
going to happen the rest of the day
today
but all i want you to know is to stay
home mind your business
i'm not doing no shows i'm not doing
nothing for the next couple days
right now this country needs to heal a
little bit and uh
that's all i give a [__] about i want to
congratulate
you guys i want to uh i'm a new
president
whoever the [__] it is and i want to let
you guys know i love you and thank you
for all your support
and your [__] love over the years i
know who you are
i know who you are and i got your back
the same way you got my back
thank you very much for letting me come
into your homes thank you very much for
letting me come into your cars
thank you very much for letting me into
your life uh
i'm not the ideal candidate but i'm your
[__] man you got me i got you
i'm with you you're with me and the rest
of these punk ass businesses want to be
with us
i love you have a great weekend enjoy
election day
enjoy the weekend and we'll see you
monday tip top magu
7 a.m ready to go uh i don't know what's
gonna happen
so we'll communicate through twitter
patreon and facebook
i love you [__] have a great
weekend stay black
and i'll see you next week thank you
very much for your time
thank you again for listening today i
want to thank you guys
for all the support and for listening
and for putting up with my [__]
twice a week i love you [__] i
want to thank my sponsors first
the joint is brought to you by lucy
nicotine
gum it's a 20th of a month and you're
still [__] smoking
you told everybody you were gonna
[__] quit but you're still [__]
smoking and poking
and [__] coughing and you know what
at the end it's not going to work out
for you all right if you're quitting
smoke if you're going to quit smoking
[__] quit but you need help that's
what lucy dot co come in
i love lucy i love it why because you
take out
you step outside you take a moment you
pop this in your mouth and you're as
good as new jack
a craving for a cigarette is only like
60 seconds you do know that
read it up you're looking to quit
cigarettes it's only like 60 seconds
and then it goes away but you get lucy
today and you're prepared for when you
get that itch
and keep on it when you're craving hits
and subscribe so you have it when you
need it
lucy gum actually [__] tastes really
good and it comes in three flavors
wintergreen
cinnamon and pomegranate and they've got
a cherry ice flavored license
that will make your [__] wig spin i
love it i love the pomegranate
i love the cinnamon and you will too
give it a try you're at a [__] age
right now where you got enough problems
in your life
cigarettes are what eleven dollars a
[__] pack go to lucy dot co right now
and use promo code
joey to get 20 percent off all your
products including gum
or lozenges that's lucy dot co use promo
code
joey at checkout are you serious about
quitting
this is the gum to help you out lucy dot
co
right now use promo code joey at
checkout
and i got to use this for the disclaimer
this product contains
nicotine derived from tobacco nicotine
is an addictive chemical
but we're trying to beat the addiction
so go to lucy.com
and be sure you use promo code joey and
quit smoking that [__] [__]
i did you should quit too the joint is
also brought to you by
draftkings i'm doing you a [__] favor
i'm putting 257 in your [__]
i'm putting 257 dollars in your pocket
this weekend
you're like joey how the [__] are you
gonna do that draftkings.com right now
we got a great [__] it's a comeback
of mcgregor baby he's coming back
and you know this [__] likes to
go for the head in the first round
so what draftkings has done is you put a
dollar on mcgregor to win by knockout in
the first round
if he does you cash in 257 dollars
you bet a little but you win a lot you
know how we do it over here at
draftkings
the kings of [__] new jersey gamblers
draftkings don't get distracted
we're still in the middle of nfl
playoffs and basketball
you got the bills against kansas city on
sunday and you got [__] tampa bay
against green bay i think on sunday or
sad i don't [__] know
i know i got the opportunity this week
and so do you to make cash
every week it starts tonight right now
tonight you got boston versus philly
you got sacramento at golden state look
at those two lines
something late listen it's the beginning
of nba everybody's focused on nfl
and ufc nobody's looking at basketball
that's where you come in tonight
and pick up an extra two three hundred
dollars so go to draftkings sportsbook
app right now download it
it's safe secure reliable plus it's your
[__] money deposit and withdraw at
your convenience
download the top-rated draftking
sportsbook app now
today use promo code joy when you sign
in to turn
one dollar into 257 dollars if mcgregor
wins or by first round knockout
saturday place your bet watch the fist
fly
and after [__] mcgregor knocks them
out you get your dick sucked like a
doctor
that's used promo code joey for new
players
to get 257 dollars if mcgregor wins by
first round knockout where are you going
to get that at
nowhere this uncle joey comes in [__]
flickers
for limited time only at draftkings and
here's what the [__] lawyers make me
say you got to be 21 or older
go get your skateboard and go skateboard
down a hill or something new jersey
pennsylvania indiana colorado
tennessee you're invited restrictions
apply
all right see draftkings.com sportsbook
for details
you got a gaming pum there's help don't
put up with that [__] call 1-800
gambling if you're in indiana call 1-809
with it but first download the draftking
sportsbook app
use promo code joey and let's win some
money should get your balls licked
and your dick sucked like a doctor plus
you're getting a stimulus check who's
better than you [__]
nobody anyway the joint is also brought
to you by
cbd lion the best in the business how do
i know
because i'm living it right now with
this [__] surgery i'm in pain
but this cbd lion got it knocked down
i'm using it as far as my
pain management cbd lion is [__]
tremendous now
is when i really get to test it and now
i see the value
of cbd lion right now go to their
website
cbdlion.com read up on cbd on the
benefits of cbd
cbn how it affects you how it can affect
your ailment
how it'll help you and then get back to
me [__]
i live and die by cbdlion.com
go in there press in church or joey on
the way out
we'll give you 20 delivered right to
your [__] house and stop
you know start living without anxiety
start living
this help cbd will help your cause
just read it and get what they think
you should be using to get better and
that's it and that's that i want to
thank cbdlion.com
i want to thank draftkings i want to
thank lucy
cole right it's lucy dot co i want to
thank them too for making a great
nicotine
gum but most importantly i want to thank
you [__] for having my back
for watching and uh for supporting me
and for
all the well wishes thank you very much
have a great weekend
and i'll see you [__] tip top
magoo monday morning
uh be safe today all right [__]
i don't know what's gonna happen
and neither do you so be safe love you
[Music]
you